hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and most of the
conversations about villains and mha
revolve around shigaraki and all for one
but the truth is that the most messed up
and unhinged villain in the entire
series is probably Dobby also known as
Toya Todoroki in some ways he is the
product of his tragic family history but
in other ways it is his own behavior and
his own Obsession that makes him perhaps
the most ruthless and dangerous villain
in all of mha in this video I will
explain the secret truth about Dobby how
he became a villain and how his rage and
obsession is about to drive him to
destroy his entire family himself
included you guys know the drill if you
enjoy our mha videos and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment right now it only takes you
a second but it really helps me with
that YouTube algorithm and if you are
one of the over 50 of people who watch
our videos but still haven't subscribed
yet please take the time to subscribe
tribe right now it is completely free
and it's the only way for you to make
sure that you're gonna see more mha
videos from us in the future finally
this video will contain mha manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned when we first meet
Dobby in chapter 57 of the story he is
introduced as just another
disenfranchised villain who was inspired
by stain's ideology to fight against the
hypocrisy of the hero Society by joining
up with the league of villains that
doesn't tell us much about Dobby's
background other than the fact that
something may have happened in his life
which led him to conclude that the hero
Society is corrupt and that it must be
overthrown we also know that Dobby is
extremely determined to keep his real
name a secret to the point that he is
even willing to fight shigaraki to the
death rather than just revealing it but
that was all the way back in chapter 68.
hundreds of chapters later we know
pretty much everything there is to know
about Dobby's past including his real
name and the truth about his family we
also know how he went from being a
hopeful kid who just wanted to become a
hero and make his father proud to one of
the most Disturbed and ruthless villains
in the entire story Dobby's real name is
of course Toya Todoroki he is the eldest
son of the number one Pro Hero Endeavor
and the older brother of Shoto he also
has two other younger siblings fuyumi
and natsuo the Todoroki family is an old
and prestigious family and they appear
to have been highly respected even
before Angie became the family patriarch
however as Angie manifested an
incredibly strong flame Quirk and as he
began climbing the top Pro Hero charts
The Prestige of the todorokis climbed
along with him once it became clear that
endeavor would eventually replace all
might as the number one Pro Hero other
families began to see the advantage of
forming an alliance with the todorokis
through marriage the himura family was
one of those families Angie Todoroki
spent most of his life trying to surpass
all might as the number one Pro Hero but
he could never achieve this goal he
became so frustrated by his inability to
overtake olomite that he decided to set
up a quirk marriage with the himura
family if he couldn't surpass almight
then he would produce a child with the
perfect overpowered Quirk and this child
Would One Day become stronger than all
might the himura family had a daughter
by the name of Rey and Rey's father
convinced her to marry NG for the good
of the family even though she barely
knew her future husband Angie chose Rey
to be his wife not out of love but
because he believed that her Quirk was a
perfect pairing for his own Quirk Rey
had a powerful ice-based Quirk and Angie
had a powerful flame-based Quirk so
Angie believed that the perfect
combination of these two would produce
the ultimate power Rey agreed to the
marriage out of a sense of obligation to
her family and this idea of a quirk
marriage is a fascinating concept and
something that is unique to the world of
Boku no hero the clear analogy in our
own world would be like a political
marriage where two families joined
together in order to increase their
wealth and influence regardless of
whether the two people getting married
actually wanted to be together the
marriage itself is not about love it is
about the political and monetary
interest of the families a quirk
marriage is also about interest but the
focus is on creating Offspring with the
best possible quirks I think that this
idea of Quirk marriage is a really good
addition to the story because
realistically if quirks were real in our
own world this type of marriage would
definitely be a thing it just feels real
and plausible within the context of that
world and of course this type of
marriage comes with its own unique set
of challenges and hardships Angie and
Rey would eventually have four children
the eldest was a son named Toya who
inherited Angie's flame-based Quirk and
then they had a daughter named fuumi who
inherited her mother's ice-based Quirk
after that they had natsuo who also
inherited his mother's ice-based Quirk
and finally they had Shoto who as we
know was born with the perfect
combination of both Fire and Ice and the
overpowered Quirk named half hot half
cold shoto's Quirk is exactly the type
of power that NG had in mind when he
embarked upon his Quirk marriage and so
once shoto's Powers manifested Angie
decided to turn Shoto into the hero who
would one day surpass all might Angie
eventually separated Shoto from his
siblings and forced him to undergo
rigorous training and in his obsession
to turn Shoto into the future number one
Pro Hero Angie neglected the rest of his
children early on in the series this is
pretty much all we knew about the
Todoroki family but as the manga
continued we learned a lot more about
the todorokis and especially about
endeavor's eldest son Toya Toya was
actually born with an incredibly strong
flame based Quirk even though it was not
the crazy combination of Fire and Ice
that Shoto possesses Angie readily
acknowledged that Toya's Quirk was even
stronger than his own and Angie
genuinely believed that Toya did have
the potential to surpass all might as
the number one Pro Hero but if that's
the case then why did Angie Focus all of
his attention on Shoto while neglecting
Toya even though Toya did have the
potential to do exactly what Angie
wanted the answer lies in the specific
way that Angie's and Rey's quirks
combined with Finn Toya although he
inherited his father's flame-based Quirk
and although his flame-based Quirk was
actually stronger than NG's Toya's body
did not develop a sufficient resistance
to fire instead his body inherited his
mother's ability to tolerate extreme
cold but not his father's ability to
tolerate extreme heat this meant that
every time Toya used his flame-based
Quirk he burned his own body and injured
himself now even after noticing this
dangerous side effect Angie still
believed that Toya could be the one to
surpass all might but after Rey and the
other children expressed their concern
that Toya's training was slowly killing
him Angie finally agreed that Toya
cannot be the one to surpass all might
Angie made this decision not because he
didn't like toy hour because he didn't
believe in him but because he actually
cared about Toya in his own strange way
and he didn't want his son to keep
getting hurt but by that point Toya had
already set his heart on becoming the
future number one Pro Hero and
surpassing all might Angie had awakened
that dream within him and Toya didn't
want to give up on his life's dream just
because using his Quirk burned his own
body a little Toya wanted to keep
training he wanted to keep getting
stronger and he wanted to make his
father proud and so Toya kept coming
home with Burns and bruises because he
kept training in secret he clearly
wasn't getting the message so Angie
decided to try a tougher approach Angie
told Toya to give up on the idea of
being a hero row and to just focus on
other things like his sister fuyumi and
his brother natsuo were already doing
Angie said this for Toya's own good if
Toya gives up on being a hero he won't
have to deal with a lifetime of Agony as
he is forced to burn himself over and
over again just so he can use his Quirk
however when his own father forced him
to give up on his dream Toya was crushed
it made him feel inadequate and
worthless and it made him jealous of his
younger brother Shoto Shoto was now his
father's favorite candidate for
surpassing all might and this was
extremely painful for Toya because he
still wanted to be the one to make his
father's dream come true eventually this
led Toya to lose it desperate to get his
father's attention and to regain his
favor Toya blew up at the family and
tried to hurt baby Shoto after this
Angie decided to separate Shoto from the
other children and to just train him in
isolation he did this to protect Shoto
from another potential attack by Toya
but what all this did was separate Shoto
from the rest of the family while also
making Toya even more upset since Angie
now spent most of his time alone with
Shoto the other children felt neglected
by their father and this was especially
true for Toya Toya felt rejected and
Abandoned and he desperately wanted to
get his father's attention and approval
and so just as NG had been absolutely
obsessed with surpassing all might for
many years Toya became absolutely
obsessed with achieving his father's
dream even if his father wouldn't help
him do it at this point Toya seemed to
have concluded that mastering his Quirk
and becoming a hero is his only purpose
in life and he continued to train more
and more until the color of his Flames
eventually changed from red to blue
during his training Toya also realized
that the power of His Flames is directly
connected to his emotions and so when
his emotions were out of control his
Flames could also spiral out of control
after his Flames changed color and
became stronger Toya regained a bit of
his confidence and he decided to show
his new power to his father he invited
Angie to come to sakoto Peak during the
holiday break because he wanted to show
his father that his Flames are now blue
and even more powerful than they were
before but Angie decided not to go to
sakoto Peak at the scheduled time he
believed that if he showed up he would
be encouraging his son to keep hurting
himself so he decided not to go in the
hopes that this would finally convince
Toya to give up on being a hero but of
course this devastated a young 13 year
old Toya and while sitting up alone on
sakoto Peak he began to cry after being
rejected by his father yet again he
became intensely emotional and because
his Quirk is directly connected to his
emotions Toya's entire body suddenly
burst into flames Toya lost control of
his own Flames which led to a massive
fire that scorched the entire Hill a
fragment of Toya's Jawbone was later
found on the scene and Toya was presumed
to have perished in the Flames Angie and
Rey's eldest son was dead and Angie's
neglect and harsh parenting style were
partially to blame for this tragic loss
the entire family was devastated
including Angie himself even though he
was nowhere close to a good father he
did genuinely care for all his children
including Toya in the early stages of
the story this doesn't necessarily
appear to be the case but as the story
progressed we realized that Angie does
care for his children in his own strange
way but instead of learning from his
mistakes after Toya's apparent death
Angie fell even deeper into his
obsession in an attempt to get his mind
off of Toya and his own sense of guilt
Angie doubled down on training Shoto to
one day surpass all might and this led
to an even greater divide within the
Todoroki family eventually Rey's mental
health deteriorated she simply could not
cope with the loss of her son and the
obsessive ruthlessness of her husband at
the same time and she snapped one day
while she was talking on the phone she
was surprised by the sudden appearance
of a young Shoto the left side of
shoto's face triggered a traumatic
episode because it reminded her so much
of Angie and she proceeded to throw
boiling water at Shoto permanently
scarring his face now as soon as the
incident occurred Rey immediately
regretted it she didn't do this
intentionally she was not in her right
mind at that moment and right after it
happened she did her best to care for
shoto's wounds but even though she
didn't mean to do this the damage was
done and the ray was eventually
committed to a mental institution for
his part Shoto did not blame his mother
for what happened he blamed his father
for traumatizing his mother to the
extent that she became mentally unstable
as we know shoto's resentment towards
his father would continue for years and
at the beginning of the story shot still
hated his father so much that he refused
to use the flame side of his Quirk
shoto's brother natsuo also felt a
similar type of resentment towards Angie
while their sister fuyumi seems to have
been a little more forgiving towards
their father but of course the real
problem child of the Todoroki family was
Toya and his story did not end in that
fire on sekoto peak in chapter 350 of
the manga we finally figured out what
really happened to Toya on secretary
Peak and how he became the ruthless
villain known as Dobby 11 years ago Toya
did nearly burn to death on sekoto Peak
but before he died he was rescued by
none other than all for one after the
Flames engulfed Toya's body the boy was
fiercely determined to survive because
he wanted so desperately to show his
father what he could do he wanted so
desperately to impress Endeavor with his
abilities and to finally make his father
proud and because Toya continued to
cling to life all for one was able to
locate him and take him away to a secret
location now even though he was still
alive Toya was severely injured and he
actually spent three full years in a
coma Toya finally wakes up inside what
appears to be some sort of children's
hospital that is also like a weird
school there are other children at this
facility and when Toya wakes up the
children call him Mr sleepyhead the
entire scene is very surreal there are
Children's Arts and Crafts all over the
walls and the vibe in general is very
friendly except we all know there is
something scary going on just beneath
the surface oh and there's another thing
here that is incredibly weird Toya's
entire body was apparently severely
burned and his face was completely
burned off but when he wakes up his
Burns seem to have been healed and his
face looks practically normal like yes
he has some stitches and scars but
otherwise he looks a lot better than
anyone was expecting him to look Toya
has no idea where he is and when he
speaks she is surprised by his own voice
his voice seems different than it was
before again Toya has no idea what
happened to him and the last thing he
remembers is burning up in the fire on
sekoto Peak he decides that he has to go
back home and he tells himself that
endeavor was probably just too busy to
come that day on secular Peak but
everyone must be worried sick about him
and he needs to apologize to his mom and
everyone else for disappearing for three
years at this point it is clear that
despite what happened on sakoto Peak
Toya is still determined to earn his
father's approval even after being in a
coma for three years Toya is still the
same boy who just wants to make his
father proud however a voice from a
computer then begins to speak to Toya
and it says that Toya's plans to return
home are no longer possible we don't
actually see who is speaking from the
computer the screen is just completely
dark but we can assume that it's either
all for one or ujiko the voice explains
that Toya's body was burned down to
almost nothing and the procedure of
putting his body back together was an
extreme dream one and it involved a lot
of experimental procedures including
grafting regenerative tissue onto him in
order to restore his burnt skin The
Voice goes on to state that Toya won't
be able to use his Quirk like he did
before he has damaged multiple organs
his nervous system is impaired and he
won't be able to feel pain normally
anymore essentially his perception of
pain has been dulled on top of that his
body apparently became weaker overall
and he will never be the same again the
voice then provokes Toya by calling him
a failure he is a failure because the
procedure couldn't bring him back to his
full strength but when Toya hears those
words he is reminded of his father and
how his father treated him as a result
he becomes visibly upset nevertheless
the voice on the computer does say that
Toya may be able to get his Firepower
back to what it was before but only if
he stays in this facility with the other
children the true purpose of this
facility was essentially to groom
children to become spare vessels for all
for one in case his Top Choice tenko
shimura AKA tomorrow shigraki failed to
meet his expectations for whatever
reason it seems that Toya had been a
candidate to become a spare vessel
because of the insane power of His Quirk
but the deterioration of his body due to
his inability to resist his own Flames
made him a failed candidate either way
though ujiku and the villains could not
manipulate Toya into staying he was
already completely driven by his
obsession with earning his father's
approval that it seemed to be his sole
driving force in life and so he refused
to remain in the facility when they
tried to keep him there by force Toya
Unleashed his Quirk burned the facility
down and escaped ujiko would later
remark that Toya AK Dabi is far worse
than the heroes can even imagine he is
so unhinged that even the villains
couldn't keep him under control would
also doesn't know how Dobby managed to
survive as long as he did because
apparently after waking up and still
choosing to keep using his Quirk his
body shouldn't have lasted even a month
and yet Toya's obsession with his father
kept him Tethered to this world and he
continued to cling to life when he
escaped the facility Toya actually went
back to the Todoroki family home he
entered the house without being noticed
and while there he saw Endeavor training
with Shoto not only that but Endeavor
was being harsh and cruel with Shoto as
if he had learned nothing from the
tragedy that happened to Toya this made
Toya think that his father had already
moved on from him he was busy training
Shoto now and it was like Toya had never
even existed Toya didn't even matter
because Shoto was the new star of the
show and the entire family had simply
moved on from Toya and not only that but
what happened to Toya didn't even make
Endeavor stop and think twice before
putting his children through so much
suffering Shoto just became the new Toya
in endeavor's mind Toya was replaced and
forgotten and all of this made Toya feel
even worse in fact it drove him to
completely snap and abandon his whole
identity as Toya for his new identity as
the villain Dobby but we know that
things weren't actually as simple as
Toya had made them out to be in his mind
Toya's mother never got over what
happened to him and neither did his
siblings even Endeavor was devastated by
the loss but because he didn't know what
else to do with his grief he channeled
everything into training Shoto this was
obviously a mistake and a terrible way
to deal with tragedy and Shoto suffered
even more because of it Endeavor
certainly made many many mistakes and he
did many many bad things so Toya does
have a right to be mad but Toya doesn't
know the full story he is jumping to
conclusions based on a few observations
but he doesn't know what has been
happening with the Todoroki family for
the three years years that he had been
in a coma after witnessing what he
believed to be evidenced that his family
had just forgotten him and moved on Toya
finally stopped being obsessed with
making Endeavor proud unfortunately he
merely replaced that obsession with an
obsession for revenge against Endeavor
he disappeared once again allowing his
family to believe that he was dead and
then he spent all his time trying to
make his Flames stronger without any
regard for the damage that he was doing
to his own body he also carefully
studied all of endeavor's actions as a
top Pro Hero in order to learn all of
his moves and all of his strengths and
weaknesses this is the point at which
Toya truly died and Dobby was born and
it happened more than three years after
the fire on sekito Peak ujiko would
later explain to the police that Dobby
is a completely different type of
villain from someone like all for one
all for one is a master strategist who
wants to avoid death and live forever
Dobby is an obsessed Berserker driven by
revenge and he will gladly Embrace death
if it will allow him to fulfill his
desire for vengeance unlike all for one
Dobby is self-destructive and insane and
he is willing to burn the entire world
to the ground including himself just to
get back at his father Dobby eventually
reappeared about eight years after he
broke out of the facility and that is
when he joined up with the league of
villains Dobby knew from the start that
all for one and ujiko were the ones who
saved his life and he even implies that
he was kept alive using the same
technology that was used to create the
nomu this led me to speculate that Dobby
may be some sort of human nomu hybrid
someone whose body has been manipulated
in the same way that the bodies of the
nomu are but whose transformation into a
normal wasn't completed and so his mind
wasn't affected this would explain why
Dobby's body still hasn't been destroyed
even though he uses incredibly
overpowered Flames without having a
resistance to those Flames Dobby's
ability to withstand damage and tolerate
pain are far beyond the level of a
normal human but it's also clear that
his mind is not the mind of a nomu and
he cannot be brainwashed and controlled
like a normal can so he may well be some
sort of human nomu hybrid but this
hasn't been confirmed just yet along
with this Revelation that Dobby's body
was subject to procedures similar to the
process of creating nomu ujiko also
states that a major reason why Dobby's
body has managed to overcome death is
his superhuman obsession with getting
revenge against Endeavor his body
continues to burn over and over again
but it is somehow being held together by
the Flames of Vengeance this is kind of
like Dobby's version of plus Ultra over
going Beyond and surpassing his limits
but not in the name of becoming a hero
or rescuing others but in the name of
making his father suffer in his pursuit
of Revenge Dobby can be both strategic
and calculating and amps absolutely wild
and ruthless at the same time we saw the
Strategic side of him when he released a
pre-recorded tape of himself exposing
Endeavor along with the truth about Toya
to all of Japan at a critical moment
during the Battle of jakku he knows that
his father worked hard all his life to
become the number one Pro Hero and now
that he achieved that rank it definitely
means a lot to him so Dobby then
releases that tape because he wants to
take the joy away from his father he
wants to make him look bad in front of
the entire country and make everyone
lose respect for the number one Pro Hero
but although Dobby clearly has that
strategic premeditated side to him his
wild ruthless and revenge obsessed side
always seems to win out in the end in
the final Arc of the story We witnessed
Dobby completely lose control and we see
his entire body engulfed in flames as he
assumes the appearance of a terrifying
flaming corpse he looks like a burning
nomu whose sole purpose is to burn down
everything around him even at the price
of his own life he vows to burn
everything precious to Endeavor down to
the ground and that will serve as proof
that he existed that will be Dobby's
revenge for the fact that his father
forgot him and replaced him with Shoto
he will kill Shoto he will kill all the
heroes and then he will kill Endeavor
himself before his own body is also
consumed by his own Flames he will stop
at nothing to accomplish his revenge and
he will sacrifice everything for that
one single purpose and in the end this
is just so sad and so ironic Dobby
became who he is today because his
father Angie was obsessed with
surpassing all might and this Obsession
drove Angie to mistreat his family
including Toya and this eventually LED
Toya to crumble under all that pressure
and lose control of his own flames on
sekito Peak so in the first half of his
life Toya witnessed his father's
Obsession completely consume his entire
family and tear them all apart but then
in the second half of his life Toya also
allowed an obsession to completely
consume him only it wasn't his father's
Obsession to surpass almight but rather
his own Twisted obsession with getting
the most brutal revenge on his father he
is so determined to make his father
suffer that he is even willing to kill
his own sibling Shoto even though Shoto
himself did nothing wrong shoto's
innocence doesn't matter to Dobby
because he just wants to see the look on
endeavor's face when his favorite child
dies ironically both Dobby and the man
he hates the most his father are men
whose lives were consumed and destroyed
by Obsession the only difference is the
type of obsession that each of them
succumbed to in the end it looks like
Dobby will probably go out in a mad
Blaze of Glory it seems that he will
push his body to the limit in his
Relentless pursuit of Revenge and he
will try to take down Endeavor while
also sacrificing his own life in the
process he may also take down a bunch of
other heroes and villains along the way
and if he did he wouldn't even care All
That Matters to him is his mission All
That Matters to him is his revenge in
some ways Dobby is just a dark mirror
image of endeavor someone who is willing
to burn everyone around him even his own
family in the fanatical pursuit of his
obsession as ujiko said Dobby is
possibly the most dangerous villain of
all because he doesn't want to take over
the world or become immortal or anything
like that he wants to go out in a blaze
of glory while exacting his revenge and
that is the only thing that matters to
him and that is what makes him so messed
up and so terrifying he is a fanatic who
doesn't even think about his own
self-interest or self-preservation the
vast majority of human beings are
pursuing their self-interests and
self-preservation and that is something
that everyone one can understand it's a
basic human instinct but Dobby is
different Dobby is obsessed and
fanatical he's like a modern day
Kamikaze and that is the truly
terrifying thing about him you can't
relate to him you can't understand him
you can't predict his actions because
his thought process is so different from
that of a normal human and that includes
both the typical Heroes and the typical
villains Dobby is like a ruthless force
of nature you can't reason with him you
can't negotiate with him and you just
have to hope that you can get out of his
way before he madly scorches everything
around him and whether you like him or
fear Him this makes him an incredibly
memorable villain if you are looking for
a video to watch next check out my
recent video on why deku's Quirk might
be secretly killing him and it's not
what you think Link in the description
let me know what you guys think about
Dobby is he the most effed up villain in
mha and if not then who do you think is
most worthy of that Crown Tolga twice
shigaraki leave your thoughts down below
if you enjoyed this mha video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment right now it only
takes you a second but it helps me out a
lot with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're one of the over 50 of people who
watch our videos regularly but haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet do me a
big favor and make this the video that
you subscribe and hit that notification
Bell to turn on all notifications you
might have watched a few of our videos
recently and so YouTube is recommending
them to you but if you don't subscribe
eventually you're not gonna see them
anymore and you're gonna miss out on a
lot you can also hit me up on Twitter
and Instagram at animeoproar as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya Space Cowboys